[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
awesome all right and we are live lord
candido here i love podcast
sportsgaming.net and who is this five
gentlemen that we have in the realm of
pax quest today hello i'm brandon
sheffield creative director of david
school
team at school let's get right into it
so
david school is a
an rpg with kind of friendship
and horror elements
uh but it's more spooky than
gory and terrifying um
kind of for all our pastel gods out
there who
wants something
who wants something spooky but
don't want like a jump scare
one thing that really drew me to the
game was i was getting a lot of persona
one guys soda vibes but i don't want to
impose that all the way or that but i
wanted to get like no more narrative
kind of generalization of the narrative
yeah so there's a it's definitely got a
shin megami tensei vibe to it
um
everybody here is
on an island the island has a university
and a prison and if you fail in the
university
uh
and in this situation
demons are
trying to come through to the human
world it's a dormant volcano and so it
has the conduit filled to the
uh
to the underworld and
nobody has seen demons for hundreds of
years they kind of pass into the idea of
legend
but uh our main character faith
right here
she
is
the last in line of a long kind of
steven hudson family so uh she's still
at least on paper understands how this
stuff works
and we've got our
tactical battle system here which
is essentially like movement equals
action so
you move as far as your character allows
and do whatever action is there so this
character for example
she'll pass through enemies and
but if i hit the one that she debuffed
for me i do too i also did a combo with
her by pushing it into her
uh so we've got some synergy also that's
right
and this is our healer name
and he if he
quite often healers aren't that useful
you keep them in the back
uh but in this case if he feels someone
who's already fully healed uh who has
full health
then he gives them an attack up
so now i can attack for two on this guy
as well all right i can go over here and
take care of this guy
i'm like uh i don't like that because
generally like you said like healers
once the
party's already full of health there's
really no other
so now you hit the action phase and you
watch it all everything that you did is
uh plays out
so again immediate action
then there's the action phase and then
it's a split again now planning phase
yeah
now we're playing again
and so i can
knock these two guys into each other
doing some more damage there
this guy is going to explode next turn
as you can see from these
he's poisoned
i could heal him up but i've already
fulfilled the victory conditions i need
to kill 5g
and i've done it
next turn i'm just gonna step on the old
victory tiles
oh
what they do individually so you kind of
learn what they do
but there are also
techniques
that you can
unlock
that will
change how they work so uh newt as the
healer for example
you can alter his heel so that it will
also point the demons
so
uh whereas he couldn't attack before and
now he could be like
kind of a paladin style doing a little
healing a little bit
i mean i hope we do
yeah i mean
in addition to
the narrative itself we have a lot of
like little side things you can do
around town and
try to keep the world
interesting
um
there's side quests you can do any side
quests you want uh before doing the main
quest the main question is time for it
and here we've got like a little side
quest where
uh newton found some weird things
and now we have a choice where we can
decide which of our friends we want to
ask and it increases our
relationship
with them
so like our relationship meter goes up a
little bit and then that'll unlock
additional story options with them and
dating potential and things like our
relationships again
we could
fish for an even fish here in
[Music]
okay
uh as you level up relationships between
two characters their combos uh
actually we had a lot of inspiration
coming from
[Music]
italian horror films from the 70s
lighting
and also
from
japanese foreign
sort of
a mix of
japan and northern europe
so these houses are very reminiscent of
pharaoh islands near iceland
and a lot of our characters have uh
georgian
clothing characteristics
very very much
[Music]
there's something that i like both about
four moving horror movies that have
practical things and also about consoles
like the biggest challenge yeah which is
where when you
when you're doing solve will love that
argument let's take a shot one of our
[Music]
you can really see the effort that was
put into it by the people that did it
like they had to really work hard to
make that happen
and similarly in
these old particles
when they do something somebody pulling
out their guts or something you're like
how did they accomplish that
and
so with our mixture of 2ds
we kind of hope
that we'll inspire oh and she got she
got changed
so we can we can break the chain by
snapping it
[Music]
is
every character
their first movement comes one ap their
second top two and third class three
and you can
um
[Music]
so they don't hurt you you can also
knock enemies into your friends and
that's how you do combos
that's just all pretty amazing
and namako's attaches
she can
uh you can just also pull them into uh
yeah
[Music]
right in this scenario
you know we're maybe like 10 of the way
through the game
and they
they're trying to figure out what all
these rituals are that are going on
around town
uh also
everyone's losing their memories
except for them and they're not really
sure what that's about but it feels like
somebody's always one step ahead of them
and uh they're trying to mail some
evidence off the island to get some help
um
unfortunately
additional things occur
what is actually happening here is that
they don't know this yet but the whole
island is getting shut off from the
outside world that's communicated
completely contained
out that's what
more
i'd love to shake it
we gotta handle it let's go
so now we gotta go fight this
all right
[Music]
especially with especially the boss i
always feel like
you know when i play turn base
things like that
there's an emotionality to the ball
power
you know
i really respect that and especially if
you got something that's really
cinematically
very good
uh so if i were standing there i'd be
dead right so that that part right there
is all right like you have to be lucky
that you're not in the spots yeah you
have to get out of there and this also
is a danger so
he's going to punch anything that that's
in there
so we're going to get out of there
so because i hit his finger
he's going to be open to attack right
here um
so but i knocked the demon into his path
so let's see what happens to that
uh
[Music]
and now we actually
so here's another example of how the
uh
the knockback is helpful so i'm hitting
this demon out of the way
so that now you can get over here to
heal
uh because previously matt damon was
blocking him
[Music]
that way then i'm going to do
very good
for demonstrating
as far as this type of adventure so
we're still figuring it out a little bit
but
probably around
20 something hours if you're uh
only doing the baby
so we'll see
that's
so now we gotta wait for him to drop his
fingers down again so that we can help
him
but this time he's dropping two oh wow
do that
[Music]
[Music]
okay i want to knock them into there
they look like me
more combo abilities more yeah and the
other party members or that's what they
actually like well this is our bait
these are main tags
these are some of our main ones here but
there's going to be 15. oh
yeah
uh a lot of them are optional
um
question to talk about
right
show
yeah
[Music]
but she'll be back
she'll be back alive
uh after the battle assuming we can
assume
yeah because
the way that this works
is
each
we're between the human and demon worlds
right now
when we're fighting demons we're in
between those spaces so if one person
can make it back to the human world they
carry everyone's essence
yeah
that's right
in a
which heals you fully so
he's all right now
at least for the time
all right
let's see what we can do
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then those gimmicks get introduced
into regular battles later on
a lot of people
on all consoles and pc and uh next year
sometimes so uh sometime 2023. this is
one of the characters
check this
out a lot of potential jrpg fans
fans check it out all right little
podcast
[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast